la historia nos ha demostrado que en
ocasiones lo imposible se hace realidad
mijail gorbachov paso de dirigir la
mismísima unión soviética-
[Música]
a la imagen de toda una multinacional
norteamericana
[Música]
familia
[Aplausos]
veremos algún día algo así en corea del
norte atentos
[Aplausos]
amigos corea del norte es un país muy
pero que muy pobre las estimaciones
disponibles dicen que el valor de su
producción per cápita es 50 veces más
pequeña que la de corea del sur menos de
1000 kilómetros de carreteras están
pavimentadas la esperanza media de vida
es la más pequeña de toda la región y a
pesar de llevar más de 22 años
recibiendo ayuda humanitaria la pobreza
está generalizada
[Música]
pero no nada de eso es lo peor lo peor
de todo es la falta total de respeto por
los derechos humanos lo sabemos los
norcoreanos viven sometidos a una férrea
dictadura a un estado policial donde los
presos políticos se cuentan por decenas
y decenas de miles de hecho según
naciones unidas entre 80.000 y 120.000
presos políticos podrían estar en campos
de reeducación en corea del norte amigos
el estado lo controla todo sin embargo
espera un momento porque en los últimos
años parece estar produciéndose un
importante cambio en este país un cambio
que tiene mucho que ver con el dinero el
comercio y el mercado veréis en teoría
en corea del norte el último gran país
comunista
bueno estado socialista que prepara la
transición para la sociedad comunista
como les gusta decir a los turistas y
que realmente no suele significar nada
más que una mala justificación del
fracaso todo prácticamente todo es
dirigido organizado fabricado y
proporcionado por el estado vivienda
salud educación alimentación empleo
pero amigos esto es la teoría la
realidad es diferente mira el sistema
estatal tiene muchas limitaciones por
decirlo de alguna manera cada vez es
menos capaz de hacer nada me explico
muchas de las fábricas y granjas
estatales tienen unos niveles de
productividad que están por los suelos
y no sólo eso en muchos casos fruto de
una maquinaria muy vieja de métodos de
producción atrasados de las sanciones
internacionales e incluso de problemas
de suministro eléctrico durante gran
parte del tiempo estos centros de
producción ni siquiera son operativos
por todo esto en los últimos años ha
cobrado peso una nueva economía privada
de la cual cada vez más norcoreanos
dependen para sobrevivir y tratar de
mejorar su pobre nivel de vida un
momento economía privada en corea del
norte mercados capitalismo pues tal como
lo escucháis atentos
el nuevo mercado norcoreano
amigos cuando kim jong-un fue declarado
oficialmente como líder supremo dictador
absoluto de corea del norte el 28 de
diciembre de 2011
muchos analistas pensaron que las cosas
podían cambiar
al fin y al cabo se trataba de un cambio
generacional con el cual llegaba al
poder una persona de apenas 28 años que
se había educado en el extranjero ni más
ni menos que en suiza sin embargo pronto
quedó claro que algunas cosas no iban a
cambiar el nuevo líder kim jong-un ha
resultado ser igual de terrible que lo
fue su padre las purgas los castigos
inhumanos la persecución de la
discrepancia el culto al líder y en
definitiva el control total han
continuado siendo las características
fundamentales de este régimen es como
una religión desde el nacimiento
aprender sobre la familia kim aprendes
que son dioses que debe ser
absolutamente obediente las élites son
tratadas amablemente y por eso se
aseguran de que el sistema permanezca
estable pero para todos los demás es un
reino del terror que sanz un médico de
42 años que logró escapar de corear el
norte
en 2014 sin embargo amigos desde que kim
jong-un llegó al poder se ha producido
algo sorprendente decenas de mercados
donde los norcoreanos comercian de forma
privada es decir se convierten en
empresarios se han abierto por todo
tal cual como lo escucháis una nueva
clase de comerciantes y empresarios está
creciendo en corea del norte
[Música]
de hecho según el instituto para la
reunificación nacional de corea
alrededor de un millón un millón de
personas trabajan directamente y en
muchos casos de forma casi exclusiva en
estos mercados que ya son una de las
principales fuentes de riqueza de este
país
ahora bien puede que te estés
preguntando pero enrique cómo surgieron
estos mercados pues amigos su origen no
es el más glamuroso ni el más feliz
[Música]
y todo comenzó en la década de los 90
cuando una hambruna causada por los
errores del gobierno la falta de medios
las condiciones climáticas y el desplome
de la unión soviética causaron estragos
en el país
[Música]
las estimaciones cifran ojo entre 1 y 2
millones las personas que perdieron su
vida por inanición en ese momento cuando
los norcoreanos luchaban por sobrevivir
fue cuando se formaron los primeros
mercados lugares donde la gente
intercambiaba todo lo que podía para
conseguir recursos con los que comprar
alimentos nos dimos cuenta de que si no
hacíamos nada moriríamos de hambre así
que empezamos a comerciar jiujiang de
repente decenas y decenas de mercados
aparecieron por todo el país salvando
miles y miles de vidas motivo
precisamente por el cual el régimen no
persiguió como se hubiese esperado este
tipo de actividades privadas
kim jong-il el padre del actual líder
fue bueno digamos que a veces toleraba
estos mercados y a veces los reprimir
[Música]
pero desde que llego kim jong-un al
poder el número de mercados privados se
ha multiplicado y las imágenes de
satélite muestran que no paran de crecer
ahora el gobierno aprueba autoriza
muchos de estos mercados a cambio de
alquilar a los comerciantes el espacio
que necesitan
y así es el propio gobierno de pyongyang
se está aprovechando de esta nueva
economía privada cuanto pues ojos según
los cálculos del instituto para la
unificación obtiene más de 220 mil
dólares por día así que precisamente por
este motivo en los últimos tiempos el
gobierno no sólo está impulsando estos
mercados sino que también ha concedido
visas a muchos empresarios y
comerciantes chinos precisamente para
impulsar esta actividad pero aquí amigos
no termina todo para nada atentos
[Música]
el mercado extraoficial
no solo la actividad de los mercados
regulados está creciendo también la de
los mercados extraoficiales es decir
aquellos que no cuentan con la
aprobación oficial de la autoridad el
mercado negro
todo esto funciona de la siguiente forma
en una economía paralela al sector
público la gente fabrica todo lo que
puede tapar todos dulces ropa y como es
natural trata de vender estos productos
en los mercados para obtener dinero
hacer posible yuanes o incluso dólares
si si dólares
[Música]
pero aún así se calcula que el 80 por
ciento de los productos vendidos en los
mercados norcoreanos proceden de china
es decir dicho de otra forma el comercio
ilegal a espaldas del gobierno también
cruza la frontera ojo con volúmenes
enormes y cada vez mayores
[Música]
por cierto muchos de estos mercados
extraoficiales se están convirtiendo en
toda una ventana al exterior para muchos
norcoreanos porque amigos en estos
lugares se pueden comprar incluso
memorias usb llenas de películas y
series extranjeras incluidas
producciones de hollywood cuando veíamos
programación extranjera teníamos que
cerrar todas las puertas y cortinas y
pretender que no habían aquí en casa
janvey kim pero puede que os estáis
preguntando contrabando cruzar la
frontera y qué pasa con los guardias y
los servicios de seguridad como toleran
este comercio ilegal pues básicamente
por dos motivos
el primero es que en pie ya no parece
existir mucha presión para combatir
estos mercados ahora veremos por qué y
segundo porque los soldados y guardias
fronterizos forman también parte del
negocio por ejemplo poniendo la mano
[Música]
y así es una forma habitual de pago
según han contado muchos de estos
comerciantes que hoy viven fuera de
corea del norte y se entregan a los
policías y los soldados cajetillas de
cigarrillos rellenas no de cigarrillos
claro sino de yuanes yenes o incluso
dólares
[Música]
estos comerciantes internacionales
compran productos en los mercados
autorizados o en el mercado negro de
corea del norte lo trasladan a china lo
venden y con ese dinero compran
productos chinos y los llevan a corea
del norte para venderlos el comercio de
toda la vida y aquí amigos con este
comercio internacional es donde si está
surgiendo una clase de personas
generalmente cercanas al poder o con
influencias o tratos con altos
funcionarios que si está haciendo dinero
dinero de verdad y que por cierto están
impulsando en pyonyang un montón de
actividades que ella no tienen nada que
ver con el viejo modelo socialista el
salario para los doctores era de unos
3500 won al mes eran menos de lo que
costaba comprar un kilo de arroz así que
por supuesto ser médico no era mi
trabajo principal mi trabajo principal
era contrabandear de noche enviaba
medicina herbaria de corea del norte a
china y con el dinero importaba aparatos
electrodomésticos un médico de 42 años
que actual
vive en corea del sur en declaraciones
al washington post como anécdota hoy por
ejemplo ya es posible comprar coca-cola
en las calles de pyongyang y según el
servicio de inteligencia de corea del
sur al menos el 40 por ciento el 40 por
ciento de todos los norcoreanos
participan de algún modo en actividades
y negocios privados sorprendidos pues
aún hay más pero antes de nada una nota
importante amigos estamos hablando de un
proceso muy incipiente en corea del
norte el gobierno sigue teniendo el
control de prácticamente todos y estos
mercados negros están creciendo es
porque en pyongyang lo están permitiendo
porque son más eficientes funcionan
mejor les permite obtener divisas y
muchos norcoreanos encuentran un modo de
mejorar sus pésimos niveles de vida algo
similar pasó en la unión soviética en
vietnam y por supuesto en china ahora sí
veamos qué más está ocurriendo
[Música]
reformas made in china
toda esta nueva clase de comerciantes y
empresarios que está emergiendo tiene un
nombre entre los coreanos don joo y como
os podéis imaginar muchos de ellos
especialmente los que de verdad hace el
dinero son personas del partido
comunista y bien conectadas con el
gobierno
[Música]
es decir forman parte de la élite
situación que aprovechan no solo para
tener un trato especial por parte de las
fuerzas de seguridad sino también para
llegar a acuerdos ventajosos con las
empresas públicas sí así es hay claras
sospechas de que muchas exportaciones
irregulares son fabricadas en empresas
públicas pero los beneficios van a parar
a estos miembros de la élite
ahora bien este nuevo planteamiento
económico no es algo que moleste en el
gobierno de pyongyang de hecho todo
apunta a que el gobierno norcoreano
quiere reproducir de alguna manera el
modelo chino es decir buscar inversión
extranjera que les permita crecer y
desarrollarse pero sin perder el control
político
fijaos desde que kim jong-un llegó al
poder su gobierno ha concedido más
libertad a las empresas públicas para
que puedan organizarse como les convenga
buscar sus propios proveedores y
clientes también ha impulsado como hemos
visto los mercados privados hace la
vista gorda con el mercado negro y las
familias en las granjas colectivas
tienen ahora asignadas parcelas
individuales cuya cosecha una vez que
cumplen con la cuota estatal pueden
utilizar como quieran pueden por ejemplo
venderla en los mercados privados
incluso ahora se empieza a hablar de
zonas económicas especiales pero insisto
amigos esto es un proceso aún muy
incipiente
[Música]
no se trata de que se vaya a producir un
cambio radical en el corto plazo sino
que ante la incapacidad del sistema
oficial los norcoreanos están
desarrollando una alternativa que mejore
su pobre nivel de vida desgraciadamente
corea del norte sigue siendo el mismo
país totalitario y pobre que era antes
de la llegada de kim jong-un y aún peor
las actuales sanciones internacionales
están causando enormes estragos en las
ya de por sí escasas capacidades
productivas del país aún con todo no me
diréis que el crecimiento de esta nueva
especie de economía paralela no es algo
sorprendente pero ahora turno para ti
crees que corea del norte tratará de
seguir el modelo chino déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo ya sabes dale a
like y no olvides suscribirte al canal
si aún no lo has hecho amigos un saludo
y hasta la próxima
i
[Aplausos]
[Música]